la mobilisation continue ce mardi les
manifestants défilent à jante en
brandissant le drapeau rouge de la ligue
nationale pour la démocratie le parti
d'aung san suu kyi
la dirigeante a été arrêté le 1er
février dernier après le coup d'état
militaire à rangoon la capitale
économique de nouveaux affrontements ont
éclaté hier
trois manifestants ont été tués mais
hier des centaines de birman sont
descendus dans la rue à l'occasion de la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes
nous sortons dans la rue parce que nous
ne sommes plus en sécurité
les gens souffrent avec la gente
militaire alors nous brandissons nos
propres jupe traditionnelle pour la
prochaine génération pour renverser la
dictature militaire
je voulais m'exprimer pour que les
femmes n'ai pas peur je veux que les
femmes se joignent à nous pour sauver
notre dirigeante en protestant aux côtés
des hommes contre la dictature militaire
je demande aux femmes de se battre
jusqu'au bout
l'agente accentue la pression sur la
population les axes de la ville de
rangoon sont bloqués par les militaires
qui ont pris le contrôle des hôpitaux
publics et des campus universitaires
des fouilles sont menées dans des
appartements à la recherche d'opposants
selon l'association d'assistance aux
prisonniers politiques
au moins 60 civils ont été tués depuis
le putsch et plus de 1800 arrêté sur la
scène internationale les condamnations
se multiplient comme son homologue à
l'onu l'ambassadeur de birmanie au
royaume uni s'est désolidarisé hier les
militaires